is that old boy right behind you yeah oh
my god dude i got a horror movie
but for people at home he told me about
this movie like 10 years ago
and i that one and then the audition
oh my god well i you invited me to your
birthday party one time yes
and uh i brought you the dvd of old boy
as a gift yes you did yeah
and i told you to watch it and um yeah
and it freaked me out and i actually one
of the
most amazing scenes i've ever seen
the way that they shot the uh the main
character
is got a whole hallway of people that he
has to fight so they built
this hallway amazing and they they cut
out the wall
and just had this guy and they just all
a one shot
of them going everybody talks about like
the scorsese you know good fella shot
that amazing one he goes in
this is basically that with like he's
also fighting
500 people yeah and then i i saw the
audition
um and i got into like you know
asian horror movies and like but they
were just so
they were so beyond what we were doing
over here i was like this is like
bananas
yeah i saw a really uh weird one
not necessarily scary but a weird one on
the criterion channel
i saw there's a movie from horror movie
from the early 70s called uh
let's scare jessica to death
no no no really i swear to god i love
horror movies let's scare jessica to
death yes and i'm telling you not
necessarily scary yeah as much as it's
it's
weird i've got to seem korean is it
korean no no no
jessica jessica that's right yeah it
wouldn't be jessica
yeah okay let's scare jessica to death
yes it's not scary
it's weird it it it could be because
here's the thing about horror movies why
i don't like them
is i i buy in people like
blair witch that didn't scare me that
scared the [ __ ] out of me i know me too
all of those movies scared the [ __ ] out
of me yeah uh
uh um that baba duke one
stop watching i shut that off i was like
i can't [ __ ] handle that well
then i didn't get to see how the thing
gets killed so for like a month every
time i turn the lights off i'm hearing
babadook
every [ __ ] time i'm just like yeah
i'm kind of uh
yeah i don't the scariest one i've seen
in the last week is an indonesian one
no not no the one that i want to
recommend them is did you see hereditary
hereditary
yes no and i won't be because if it
freaks you out i don't know
i'm easy to scare but that [ __ ] me up
it
[ __ ] i've seen it three times since we
saw it that first time
and i get so [ __ ] scared
you have to watch it billy please guys
you a question because i don't
understand
what is it why would you want to feel
like i hate that
feeling me too like i can watch like a
gangster movie whatever but i even
watched like casino
got too like yeah i got a little like
when he's watching his brother
getting you know killed i was just like
i'm actually
uh chris rock is in the new uh
fargo and there's a storyline in it
that's making it
on watching as a parent yeah yeah sort
of uh
i'll trust you with my kid if you trust
me with your kid just trying to get
through that
yeah yeah it's just like like i don't i
get like
why i love movies is because i if i'm
into it like i am
i'm in it i'm in it i can't do rape
scenes
there's this movie called irreversible
and there's a 10-minute rape scene
in a tunnel and it's so realistic
and literally like 10 seconds in you're
like all right i'm out
i'm out i can't do it it's so
uncomfortable i remember when that movie
came out
yeah i remember when that came out
because that was a that was a big uh
deal it was a big it was a controversial
does it go backwards
it goes backwards the whole movie yeah
right and there's this
like and it's like um you don't have
editors
cut it down can i can i tell you what's
i've never understood
i don't understand sex scenes in
mainstream hollywood movies
i don't understand it's like am i now
watching a porno yeah like when they
really go
yeah because i watched uh an old movie
one time
and these uh